[Musique]
c'est avec vous Anthony Saint-Léger
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Nadia bonsoir à
tous
au Mondial des
internautes d'origine camerounaise
camerounaise il était à l'auteur du seul
but du match effectivement est plus
précisément des supporters auraient
attaqué la maison de famille de Brel
mbolo alors tantôt celle de ses parents
celles de son père ou même celle selon
les publications de ça grand-mère et
selon les différentes publications selon
donc les différents commentaires il y a
ceux qui prennent le parti de ces
supporters en colère et le considère
comme un traître du fait de son origine
camerounaise et d'un but donc contre le
avec Cameroun et puis il y a ceux au
contraire qui vont chercher à condamner
ce comportement à chaque fois en tout
cas il y a la même vidéo qui est
utilisée pour illustrer ce ce propos
c'est celle-ci où l'on voit
effectivement des personnes en colère et
qui pour certaines vont jeter des choses
contre un bâtiment on voit aussi dans la
foule de cette foule en colère donc des
drapeaux à la fois des drapeaux du
Cameroun et puis des maillots aussi de
l'équipe nationale du Cameroun ces
vidéos qui ont été partagées tout
réseaux sociaux confondu des centaines
de milliers de fois alors est-ce qu'on
peut dater la vidéo la date à hier et
particulièrement située dire que ça se
passe au Cameroun et bien c'est un
double oui Nabilla oui elle a eu lieu
hier cette scène et oui elle a eu lieu
au Cameroun sauf que le contexte est un
petit peu différent explications on va
revenir sur l'une des publications qui
se trouvait sur un des commentaires
pardon qui se trouvait dans une
publication sous la vidéo il y est
question de l'Agence des néo des néo
c'est une société camerounaise qui
distribue l'énergie au Cameroun on parle
de délestage pendant le match du
Cameroun
ce commentaire ça va nous mettre la puce
à l'oreille parce que lorsque l'on va
revenir sur la vidéo en question et
qu'on la regarde attentivement on note
ici effectivement qu'au cours de la
vidéo on retrouve ce comptoir avec le
nom de la société en question le nom et
Neo ça nous donne donc un premier indice
quand ensuite on recherche sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est deux mots et néo
délaissage et qu'on les cantonne à une
seule date celle du 24 novembre donc
hier jour de la rencontre et bien on
retombe sur différentes publications
notamment celle-ci une publication une
page facebook plus précisément actualité
de l'Est un média qui est spécialisé sur
l'actualité camerounaise dans la région
de berthois berthois c'est ici à l'Est
du Cameroun et sur la page en question
voilà bertois sur la page en question on
va effectivement retrouver une
publication avec la même vidéo virale
mais la légende a absolument rien à voir
en l'occurrence il s'agit rien à voir
avec la légende de la publication virale
en l'occurrence il s'agit du siège des
néo attaqué par les populations
furieuses du délestage en cette période
marquée par la Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar et effectivement c'est
une information qui a été confirmée à
plusieurs reprises ou plus exactement
par plusieurs sources aux observateurs
de France 24 d'abord par le rédacteur en
chef de actualités s donc le média en
question qui parle d'un mouvement
d'humeur qui a été qui a eu lieu pendant
la rencontre Cameroun Suisse qui avait
donc le hier lié à une interruption
d'énergie et qui est en rentrée en
incident en tout cas qui n'a pas duré
longtemps puisque la situation est
rentrée dans l'ordre rapidement nous
dit-il voilà pour la première
confirmation l'effet on est ensuite été
confirmés cette fois par la société et
Neo toujours aux observateurs de France
24 qui elle vous voyez parle d'un bureau
et néo assiégé là encore pendant le
match Cameroun - Suisse des personnes
qui réclamaient le retour d'énergie
électrique et l'interruption vous le
voyez à environ la durée durée environ
20 minutes et qui mentionne quelques
dégâts d'autres vidéos qui sont
présentes sur les réseaux sociaux vont
montrer regardez la même scène mais sous
un angle différent elle effectivement
lorsque l'on va comparer les images en
question alors là on va mettre la vidéo
que je viens une image de la vidéo que
je viens vous montrer et là on va mettre
deux exemples de la vidéo virale et vous
voyez que constitue un puzzle en fait
vous avez ici
le bâtiment que vous retrouvez
exactement ici de la vidéo virale et
c'est gris qui sont bleues alors la
définition ici n'est peut-être pas
forcément de très bonne qualité et bien
elle se retrouve ici des camerounais en
colère donc bien évidemment ça vous
l'aurez compris mais en aucun cas ça n'a
avoir avec le score et plus exactement
le but marqué par Brel Embolo et du fait
de son origine camerounaise et par
ailleurs et j'en terminerai là-dessus
aucun incident autour de la famille de
Brel Embolo n'a été rapporté et ça ça a
été confirmé par la police aux
observateurs de France 24 et aussi par
les représentants du joueur qui sont au
courant de cet enfant qui en ont eu
connaissance mais qui n'ont pas fait de
commentaires supplémentaires quant à
quelconque incident merci beaucoup
Antony on peut retrouver d'ailleurs
cette chronique sur vos réseaux sociaux
merci à vous